It's an edgy cartoon about crime-fighting
cryptids. A situational dramedy about
dysfunctional families. A mix of urban fantasy,
cultural myths, and science-fiction. Gargoyles
is all of those things, but keep watching to find
out what only adults notice when they watch it!
Think back to the 1980s and early '90s, and you
won't recall too many shows that embrace long-form
storytelling the way many shows do today. Plots
that move their way through dozens of episodes or
more and characters whose stories grow and evolve
over the course of shows from that era are fairly
rare. Alongside other like-minded programs
such as X-Men: The Animated Series, Disney's
Gargoyles helped normalize animated television
following characters across series-long journeys.
Characters grow and change from episode
to episode; their relationships evolve,
and they learn lessons that carry them
into future stories. At the same time,
events that take place as far back as the
pilot episode — set a thousand years in the
past — remain relevant well into the second
season. According to creator Greg Weisman,
his staff of writers worked hard to create a
complex web of connected stories, characters, and
events that build a rich series-spanning tapestry.
Weisman wrote on his website's expansive FAQ,
"Some of it was dumb luck. Serendipity [...]
[other times] we planned ahead […] Personally,
I had some long-term plans."
Originally, Weisman envisioned Gargoyles
as one sprawling, serialized saga,
which has long been the custom for comic
books and daytime soap operas. In the end,
that approach became key to the show's appeal.
In many kids' action cartoons, heroes are
good, villains are bad, and that's all you
need to know. In Gargoyles, things aren't quite
so black and white. The show includes baddies
with agendas that aren't necessarily limited
to total destruction or world domination.
Xanatos — a ranked member of the Illuminati — is
mostly driven by wealth and power, only resorting
to violence when it's necessary. Surprisingly,
he becomes an ally of Goliath and company by
the end of the series. Demona — a villainous
gargoyle — is determined to wipe out humanity,
viewing herself as a crusader for justice.
Derek Maza, who becomes the mutant Talon,
has a tragic backstory and mostly turns to
crime as a means to regain his humanity.
Some antagonists aren't really
villains at all — more victims
of unfortunate misunderstandings. The
immortal man Macbeth initially seeks
to use the gargoyles for his own vengeful
ends, but eventually reveals himself as a
noble warrior whose anguish twisted
him into an unscrupulous antihero.
The kids in the audience might not realize
these details sets Gargoyles apart from
the afterschool animation pack, but
adults can certainly pick up on it.
Apart from a routine fight for justice, Gargoyles
often centers its stories on the timeless lessons
of parenting. The elder gargoyle Hudson acts
as the family's wise, grandfather-like figure,
offering Goliath counsel on how to best teach
his youthful clan. Goliath often fills the role
of a reluctant surrogate father to the younger
gargoyles Lexington, Brooklyn, and Broadway.
"The three of you may explore. But stay close
to the building, and stay out of sight."
Goliath eventually finds himself with
his own direct offspring — Angela,
his daughter with Demona. Several stories focus
on Goliath and Angela's relationship — Goliath
struggles to accept her at first, but he learns
to embrace his new fatherly role over time.
Other complex parent-child relationships include
Xanatos and his father, and Goliath and his clone,
Thailog. Any parent who has had to watch their
child go astray can relate to the pain Goliath
feels watching Thailog turn evil. The show's
parental themes encompass human characters,
gargoyles, and the magical beings of
Avalon, but they might fly over kids' heads.
Gargoyles began airing shortly after
the 1994 conclusion of sci-fi TV staple,
Star Trek: The Next Generation, and
immediately became a new home for two
of TNG's biggest stars. Jonathan Frakes
and Marina Sirtis — who play Commander
William Riker and Counselor Deanna Troi,
respectively — voice David Xanatos and
Demona. But Frakes and Sirtis weren't the
only actors to cross over from Star Trek.
During the original two-season run of Gargoyles,
nearly a dozen actors from multiple Star Trek
series lent their vocal talents. Michael Dorn —
Worf on TNG — voices Goliath's brother Coldstone.
Brent Spiner — the iconic TNG android Data —
breathes life into the mischievous trickster Puck.
Nichelle Nichols — Uhura in the original 1960s
Star Trek series — voices Diane, the mother of
Talon and Elisa Maza. Star Trek: Voyager star Kate
Mulgrew even appears as the magical queen Titania.
Other notable Star Trek alumni
— including LeVar Burton,
Colm Meaney, and Avery Brooks — make one-off
appearances that liven up their episodes.
We talk about diversity and representation
in sci-fi and fantasy much more today than
we did in the '90s. In that respect, Gargoyles
was way ahead of its time by showcasing a wide
array of cultures and backgrounds. Elisa Maza —
the show's sole human lead character — was not a
typical cartoon hero by mid-'90s standards.
When we meet her family, we learn that her
father is of Native American descent, and
her mother's family comes from Nigeria.
Heroes and villains from Gargoyles hail
from across the globe, with BIPOC characters
appearing regularly throughout the series.
During the Avalon World Tour arc in Season 2,
Gargoyles introduces the viewers to
several new figures — human and gargoyle
alike — from countries including Japan,
Egypt, and Guatemala. The wide range of
cultural and ethnic backgrounds represented on
Gargoyles helped it become a landmark series.
Alongside its many sci-fi,
fantasy, and magical elements,
Gargoyles weaves plenty of real-world
cultural myths into its ever-expansive
universe. In the world of Gargoyles — which
is itself inspired by old Scottish tales of
stone statues — folklore is entirely real,
and the source of a number of supernatural
beings seen throughout the series. Sometimes
they're friends, and sometimes they're foes.
In the episode "The Hound of Ulster," Goliath,
Elisa, and Angela arrive in Ireland and encounter
a hero and a villain from local mythology —
the warrior Cú Chulainn and his greatest enemy,
a malevolent banshee. The episode "Mark of the
Panther" sees the gang in Africa — where they
meet Anansi, a major folktale character
who takes the form of a giant spider. In
the episode "Double Jeopardy," they even
encounter the Egyptian death god, Anubis.
"Rich and poor, young and
old, all are equal in death."
To go along with these historical legends,
Gargoyles also includes some modern myths
that some kids probably assume are just
wild animated adventures. For example,
the episode "Sentinel" reveals the fictional alien
origins of the Easter Island heads. Apparently,
Greg Weisman's love of tall tales
isn't limited to ancient legends.
Each Gargoyles episode is more than a mere
adventure: they often end with an important
message — a lesson for kids and adults alike.
Of course, many children's shows from the '80s
and '90s attempt to cultivate positive values
in their young audiences, but Gargoyles never
gets as heavy-handed as the likes of G.I.
Joe or Captain Planet and the Planeteers.
Nearly every episode of Gargoyles puts a major
character into a difficult situation with a
challenging moral dilemma. They might make a
critical mistake, but they usually learn a lesson
in the process. Some of these lessons are as
simple as judging between right and wrong; other
times, the lesson might pertain to an internal
problem a character needs to focus on overcoming.
The series tackles various social issues,
too. The landmark episode "Deadly Force"
addresses gun violence when Broadway accidentally
shoots Elisa, causing him to despise firearms. The
episode "A Lighthouse in the Sea of Time" brings
up the difficult topic of adult illiteracy,
with Hudson struggling with shame due to his
inability to read. After losing his way at
daybreak, Hudson meets a new friend who teaches
him it's never too late to learn something new.
The series deals with important topics like
crime, poverty, and class inequality, leaving
viewers with something to think about — even if
the kids watching don't realize it immediately.
As nonhuman beasts living in New York
City, Goliath and his clan are forced
to keep their existence a secret. They hide
from the fear and hostility they correctly
expect from ordinary humans. Yet, despite
their cautious posture towards outsiders,
Goliath forms a bond with Elisa,
leading to a star-crossed romance.
However, it's the story of Demona might best
exemplify the show's attempts to explore the
roots of xenophobia. In recurring flashbacks
that begin in 994 AD, Goliath's onetime mate
becomes immortal, and witnesses mankind's
brutality toward her people throughout the
centuries. She and her numerous gargoyle clans are
persecuted and exterminated by the humans led by
Gillecomgain, a gargoyle hunter who passes his
irrational hatred down through the generations.
"Demona!"
"The Hunter! How many times must I destroy you?"
Over the course of its run, Gargoyles
presents bigotry and intolerance as
more dangerous than any villain. In the
final episodes of the second season,
Gillecomgain's descendants stir
up public fear of gargoyles,
and it takes a newly reformed Xanatos to save
them. Ultimately, Gargoyles demonstrates the
dangers of intolerance, hopefully influencing
its young audience to be loving towards others.
The drama on Gargoyles is far-reaching, deep,
and complex. Dare we call it ... Shakespearean?
Tragic villains, family turmoil, and love
and loss form the basis for many episodes,
as is the case for the best of Shakespeare's
plays. Some character names of the Gargoyles
universe — such as Puck, Macbeth, Oberon,
and Titania — are directly lifted from major
Shakespearean characters. Considerable chunks
of Gargoyles mythology are borrowed from the
plays Macbeth and A Midsummer Night's Dream, and
the backstory of the Gargoyles villain Macbeth
mirrors the play of the name name. At one point in
the series, we learn that many of the fantastical,
mythology-based characters we've met are
called the Children of Oberon — they're
offspring of the King of the Fairies, as
referenced in A Midsummer Night's Dream.
To children of the '90s, Gargoyles must have
seemed like any other fantasy cartoon with
mighty gods, monsters, and magical beings. Adults
at the time — much as now — might notice how
Gargoyles informs its young audience about classic
literature without making it feel like homework.
In addition to historical influences ranging
from Shakespeare to old-world folklore,
Gargoyles flies into the territory of
film noir and mystery, now and again. Matt
Bluestone — Elisa's partner in the NYPD — serves
as a clear homage to old-school detective stories.
Never is this more on display than his two solo
stories, "The Silver Falcon" and "Revelations."
Titled as a homage to the film noir classic
The Maltese Falcon, the former episode centers
on Matt's quest to uncover the truth behind the
Illuminati — a secret society that has allegedly
existed for centuries. Matt goes missing,
prompting Elisa and Broadway to team up and
track him down in the style of the old detective
movies Broadway has recently been enjoying on TV.
"Revelations" serves as a follow-up to "The
Silver Falcon," in which an aging gangster
called Mace Malone offers Matt membership
into the Illuminati. Told in flashbacks,
"Revelations" has all the hallmarks
of an old-school pulp mystery,
and Gargoyles makes no attempt to hide its use
of tried-and-true classic film noir tropes.
When you think of Gargoyles, its fantasy
elements are probably the first things
that pop into your mind. Whether it's
the magic spell that put the gargoyles
into a thousand-year slumber, or their
encounters with King Arthur, Macbeth,
and the fay trickster Puck, the series
seems firmly planted into the fantasy genre.
However, Gargoyles also mixes in sci-fi
— including aliens, virtual realities,
and time travel. Even in the first handful of
episodes, Xanatos builds an army of robotic
gargoyle copies. But nowhere is this blending
of genres more evident than in the character of
Coldstone, Goliath's long-lost brother. Found
in pieces after being smashed centuries ago,
Coldstone is resurrected by Xanatos
using science and sorcery — specifically,
a magic spell to reform his mind, and robotic
augmentations to reconstruct his body.
"As you said, it's alive."
Though such genre-bending might
be more commonplace today,
it was likely not something many
kids paid attention to in the 1990s.
After the second season of Gargoyles, the series
returned for a third — featuring a new status quo
and an all-new title. The previous season had
ended with the existence of the gargoyles being
revealed to the world, and an unexpected
rescue from their persistent foe, Xanatos.
Gargoyles: The Goliath Chronicles began airing
on Saturday mornings in 1996. It follows Goliath
and his clan, living back in their original
castle, owned by Xanatos. In these 13 episodes,
the gargoyle crew is hounded by a villainous
group of gargoyle hunters called the Quarrymen.
The Quarrymen became the overarching baddies for
the remaining episodes, though were unable to
match the quality of the villains from the first
two seasons. The animation also looks cheaper,
and the stories aren't quite as compelling. Many
Gargoyles fans agree that the revamped series was
a huge disappointment, with its lower quality
partially responsible for its cancellation.
As cartoons come and go, children
watching in 1996 might not have
realized what was happening. Only adults
would have noticed that series creator
Greg Weisman was not listed as producer,
writer, and creator for this final season.
According to Weisman, Disney didn't originally
plan for a third season, but their acquisition of
ABC led to a revival for Gargoyles as a Saturday
morning cartoon, rather than a show formatted
for the afternoon. With an entirely new creative
team on board, the company wanted him to take a
demotion from producer to editor, which ultimately
led to his departure. As Weisman recalled,
"I tried to guide them, but they
didn't really listen too much."